heute wird in berlin die mutter des
berüchtigten kleinstaats arafat abou
chaker beerdigt um 11 uhr in berlin
schöneberg soll die bestattung
stattfinden
viele gäste werden erwartet und die
polizei ist auch schon vor ort bereits
am mittwochabend war die polizei bei
einer trauerfeier für die frau in
berlin-neukölln dabei und achtet auf die
einhaltung der korona hygieneregeln 250
gäste waren dabei erlaubt 100 sollen
tatsächlich dort gewesen sein
arafats mutter soll vor ihrem tod wegen
einer corona erkrankung behandelt worden
sein damit er seine mutter noch einmal
sehen könnte soll sogar sein aktueller
prozess gegen bushido unterbrochen
worden seien
der clan abou chaker wir stellen ihnen
die familie jetzt noch einmal vor der
prozess um arafat abou chaker und drei
seiner brüder in dem rapper bushido
zeuge ist wurde am montag abrupt beendet
grund dafür dass mir abou chaker die
mutter der angeklagten starb nach
längerem krankenhausaufenthalt während
über die verstorbene nur wenig bekannt
ist sind ihre söhne und deren
gesetzesbrüche berühmt und berüchtigt
nach sarah busacca ist der älteste sohn
das dritte kind er wird als kopf des
abou chaker clans beschrieben hat sich
in der berliner unterwelt unter anderem
als kontrolleur für den straßenstrich
rund um die kurfürsten und oranienburger
straße gezeigt aber fatah busacca wird
2008 bekannt als er das management von
rapper bushido übernimmt in dem
gemeinsamen label waren auch rapper eko
fresh und kay one vertreten
doch arafats geschäfts taktik ist
rigoros auch wenn er strafrechtlich noch
wenig abbekommen hat jetzt ist er wegen
versuchter schwerer räuberischer
erpressung gefährlicher körperverletzung
freiheitsberaubung und beleidigung gegen
bushido angeklagt eineinhalb jahre nach
ihm kommt rommel zur welt er wurde 2018
angeklagt nachdem er einem taxi fahrer
während der fahrt gegen den kopf schlug
und dadurch einen unfall verursachte
doch wenn er und das opfer sich vor
schuldspruch aussergerichtlich einigten
kam es zu keiner strafe mohammed
moawalla ist größter bekannte angriff
war der sogenannte pokerraub 2010 im
berliner hyatt-hotel erbeuteten
kleinkriminelle 242.000 euro
bevor sich ihnen ein sicherheitsmann in
den weg stellte und die polizei
eingreifen konnte mohammed war der kopf
dahinter
das jüngste kind der familie 2009 10
wurde er festgenommen weil er seine
kinder von dänemark nach deutschland weg
von der mutter entführt hat der heute
39-jährige wird genauso wie seine brüder
im aktuellen fall wegen beihilfe
angeklagt doch trotz laufender anklage
haben die ab und schlag alles zeit zum
trauern
der nächste prozesstag ist erst für den
30 september vorgesehen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren